[Music]
ironing your clothes seriously who does
this anymore you're gonna throw a jacket
over that shirt anyway
this is about a cap successor not an
iron man the criminal organization known
as laf
is targeting captain vassan one of our
military liaisons
laf i share the confusion sam another
acronym for an organization in the mcu
does this one stand for lazy as f
because that's what all this acronyming
is starting to feel like and sam
this has to be subtle character says
something has to be subtle because it
will be oh so hilarious at how not
subtle it will actually
be cliche not looking before you leap
there's like a whole saying in
everything
sending intel to your hud right now i
love how tech in the mcu just works
every time to send extremely complex
data and audio despite
loud environments or long distances and
when i say love what i actually mean is
i'm severely doubtful of
did everyone brush up on all the
previous captain american films and
bring your notes because we're barely
four minutes in and we're already having
to remember who the
fat rock is and why we should care okay
fun fact this is why everyone working at
shield headquarters has to wear
lead-lined clothing
falcon is an equal opportunist when it
comes to taking a peek
instructions from inside an nba rules
committee meeting about james harden
somehow makes it into the script
red wing engage considering the high
noise interference environments it's
used in
i'm calling it a design flaw that
engaging red wing is done with voice
activation
this should be via glove or arm button
unless of course it's just an excuse to
say
red wing so the fan clan can excrete
some pleasure fluid
also i love how red wing just knows that
engage means go use your genital laser
to cut an exact hole out of this plane
at a very specific door seam
with no further instruction nice of bat
rock to be standing right by the doorway
so falcon could get the easy attack
on him and if bat rock was standing
right there when the door flew open
shouldn't have been sucked out of the
plane with it pilot gets hit by a
ricochet bullet and immediately dies and
slumps onto the controls to make the
plane dive to increase the tension of
the action scene cliche
we're playing all the hits today kids
geez how fast this guy secure this
hostage and get into a full jumpsuit
after he knocked falcon out by
checking notes kicking him so he hit his
back on something it's impressive for
sure
after the pandemic i swear it'll take me
20 minutes to get into a pair of jeans
let alone don a full body flights it
with a strap-on hostage
laughing about a basic front flip when
human life is on the line okay
fine this action scene is pretty amazing
it's clear that marvel's refusing to
pull punches with this stuff and putting
resources into making it look
spectacular
i guess i'll tip my sin cap with a quick
removal well done
still the guys in these helicopters not
being able to hit sam even once is utter
bullsh
and i will be sinning
but you didn't say engage engage is like
the pleas of the robot world
you have to say the magic word look i
don't have time to go all mythbusters on
this move and figure out the complexity
of matching the three-dimensional
movement of two independent bodies one
of which has
giant blades creating enough downforce
to stay in flight so let me just say
nope keep going we're close well
okay i mean i was planning on landing
the helicopter right here but if you say
so i will go ahead and
what was it again oh right keep going
also the commander told sam earlier on
the plane they were already in
restricted airspace so why does bat rock
think traveling into a different
restricted airspace will make a
difference
this face ah heads up you're about to
fly into libyan airspace not sure why
this matters because once again the
commander told sam that they were
already in restricted airspace they're
already committing all the illegals
how many choppers do these random
terrorists have we've seen at least two
blown up and this third is followed by a
fourth loaded to the gills with missiles
for a last-second tension builder i'm
just trying to figure out the plan here
hijack a plane take a hostage and then
was the plan always to jump from that
plane
even though they had control of it they
had all the equipment to do so but if
falcon never shows up they just fly
direct right but still they have a flock
of fully loaded choppers at the ready
just in case i mean there's planning
ahead and then there's omniscience and
this feels more like the second
also now is as good a time as any to
remind you that hawk fly abandoned an
unmanned plane to just continue on its
way flying over the desert
sure they showed us it went to autopilot
but that sucker was flying to libya too
and it's never mentioned again and i
need to know how did they stop that
plane
this works working on next level
high-tech equipment outdoors in a sandy
environment
online there's just been a lot of a lot
of stuff about steve actually
crazy crazy conspiracy theories some
people they think that
he's in a secret base on the moon mcu
and on
showing us recognizable washington dc
architecture but still feeling the need
to splash washington dc across the
screen
sam even said in the last scene he was
headed there i appreciate they're giving
this shield the white glove treatment
but papadoc was clearly putting his
fingerprints all over that thing
i say you're gonna make me ask why
didn't you take up the mantle
damn it's almost not fair that marvel
can just bring in don cheadle off the
bench for a few minutes and add this
much gravitas to the proceedings in fact
it's
so not fair that instead of taking
another sin off i'm adding one for how
not fair it is
so deal with it half hour before last
call
i can't guys i have to prep for
tomorrow's session we've seen a lot of
stories on the dangers of alcohol but
here we have a situation where going to
get a drink would have saved a guy's
life
i actually can't say how i feel about
that messaging but i do appreciate the
attempt to flip the storytelling norm
any second now bucknutz is going to
burst through this painting but why does
he wait
if he's going after this group bust the
hole grab your guy and get the buck out
of there
also considering the winter soldier is
borderline unstoppable does he really
even need to perform this kind of
subterfuge
his target is now more aware of the
attack than he would have been if bucky
had been hiding in the guy's room or
dropped down from the ceiling
and the target has a better chance to
get away because bucky has created the
obstacle of drywall that didn't need to
be there
sleeping on a hardwood floor i said
hardwood
you're a civilian now maybe the show
will explain how this is possible maybe
it won't but
i can't imagine there is any explanation
for how a murderer on the level of
bucky barnes would be allowed to freely
walk amongst the population regardless
of the fact that he was manchurian
candidated he still killed a
ton of people i like bucky i like seeing
sebastian stand in the mcu but i will
never be able to buy he can just go get
some baby back ribs at his local chili's
whenever he wants to this could have
been handled differently
this should have been handled
differently with your history the
government needs to know
that you're not gonna
gonna what root route for the home team
what was rule number two nobody gets
hurt it's a big one and why isn't it
rule number one james buchanan barnes
would be excellent at tv sins
i know that you have been through a lot
but
in case you confused it with the lacroix
that you drink even though it tastes
like you're licking the bottom of a
swampy rhinoceros foot
uncle sam these kids solely exist so
that someone gets to call him uncle sam
and everyone can turn to their neighbor
while watching you go get it
uncle sam like the military but shut up
cece we all get it
try the whole online dating thing it's
pretty crazy also there's that whole
you're a former hitman for hydra thing
perhaps remove the part of your profile
that reads former hitman for hydra but
now i say hell no to that
hmu speaking of that why does no one
recognize bucky i know when he was
winter soldiering he had the half mask
but there have been pictures of him in
newspapers without the mask i'm not
saying he's tom cruise trying to walk
down the street in peace but sam
out of falcon gear and torres had some
random guy walk up to them and call them
avengers if there are strangers that
know
torres there's surely plenty of people
who would recognize bucky
tiger photos i mean half the time i
don't even know what i'm looking at it's
it's a lot sound like my dad your dad
laments that dating apps are full of
tiger photos
keep a couple games around for boring
chefs and i picked up battleship and i
swear it has nothing to do with your
previous connection to war or any
thematic ideas of subterfuge that the
show we're on is playing with
it was a random game i promise
uh hit why aren't you using the
electronic noises when you're clearly
playing electronic battleship
also why have you only placed two of
your ships and why do you have three
hits on this ship when she's only marked
one and why are you surprised she
guessed
b8 it's the obvious next guess after she
hit on e d
and c8 and later bucky's going to take
two guesses in a row
show obviously doesn't know how to
battleship correctly
there's no word for someone whose kids
die
it is fairly recent but the sanskrit
word villama has come into usage
it means against the natural order of
things and though i could add a sin for
the show not mentioning this
i'd rather this be a sin for the type of
grief that i can't even imagine and
no one should have to experience a date
this is a great reveal
even if you see it coming it perfectly
conveys the depth of what bucky is
dealing with and how his past actions
have affected so many other lives
marvel does the pew pewing as well as
anyone but they can also bring the
character moments
and the tears i'm not crying you're
crying suzy
disobedience so i don't know how
jurisdiction works here but i don't have
to place you under arrest
taurus saw what this guy just did to the
cop does he really think pulling a gun
on him was going to be effective
doria survives this i knew it falcon
really
dainty butterfly hands is what got this
guy to falcon you know what i've always
wondered
how do you guys make a living oh oh i
know let me try this one
it's a tv show and it's fiction so quit
asking dumb questions because you're
ruining television shows and i like the
other narrator better anyway
how am i doing i understand their
priorities are to secure a loan at the
bank but
maybe leave a smidge earlier and give
the food to those in need before the sun
bakes it in the back of your truck
oh my god sam you better look at this
hey you better come take a look at this
cliche and news position at the same
time
you're straight up mocking me now aren't
you marvel look when you're using cgi to
dh kurt russell 40 years younger and
stuff him into a captain america suit
technology has officially gotten out of
hand
did you know that we create monthly
exclusive videos for our singing club
members bonus outtakes
i don't know peter meth is a hell of a
drug extra sins videos
strange things are a foot at the circle
k
and even member chosen sin commentaries
i love this
i love this this kind of of a sin
because it's just
it's so silly pick our next video and
see the exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spiders
is he wearing a parachute no
no he wasn't here come on
lovely
[Music]
so now that you've stopped fighting
what do you want
[Music]
peace we are the united states
government
we don't do that sort of thing
uh and my favorite vitamin i might add